[Music]  hey I was reading about mr. Bachmann  Michele Bachmann's  Tea Party husband and it said that he is  a psychiatrist and a right-wing  Christian and he says that he can cure  homosexuality that's what he said he  said that he can pray the gay away if  you pray hard enough the homosexuality  will leave their body and it might not  work every time and that might be  frustrating so what I suggest you try if  that doesn't work is get down on your  hands and knees and suck the  homosexuality out of them I know you can  I'm not sure you can pound it out of  them but I think you can suck it out of  them if you try it also pays better  these guys will pay you to try it and it  may not work it may work I'm just saying  good luck with curing homosexuality  because that's where most of our  problems come from Cheers  welcome back today's